relying on technology for reproduction
after revolting and fighting against the
gynocentric government this is a ram
morti episode oh is it really I told you
man I'm impressed Morty I think mtow
when you think about it mtow has always
existed because most men haven't
reproduced yeah so it's interesting how
it's women didn't care about mtow when
it wasn't the men they wanted yeah but
now that the men they want are like you
know maybe I'll just have side chicks
for a lifetime it like enrages them
they're like well you you you can't like
men shouldn't sleep around either and
I'm like well we do it first my my
prediction for the under 21s I actually
think women are going to be less
promiscuous a lot of only fans workers
and that stuff but I do think you are
going to see lower like number of sexual
partners Ellie come here what are you
doing why are my legs so tasty she
literally loves my legs what is going
you can like what up guys welcome to the
just cly things YouTube channel and
welcome to my reaction series today I
have a special guest on the channel
welcome
Christine before I start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel bring that
notification Bell make sure you like the
video on your way in also get yourself a
women shouldn't vote t-shirt the
material is so soft right so soft like
the softest t-shirt I've ever worn yeah
it's is very nice so if you want all of
the women come up to us right and the
men we get stared at yeah without a
doubt without a doubt so if you guys
want to be the ultimate alpha male get
yourself a women should have vote
t-shirt today so Christine Christine how
how is the audacity Network treating you
I feel so oppressed no I'm
joking it's great I literally get to do
what I love um I have fun I get to talk
about things I care about and uh yeah
it's definitely better than my last job
and guess who guess who just re guys
guess who just recognized your video the
Tates they both they both saw her video
she did breaking down the [__]
charges yeah and it's it's crazy to
think I I wrote this and filmed that
video when they were still in prison
yeah so the fact that they've now seen
it and the fact that like them and you
guys got me into this kind of content
and now I'm here working with you and
the Tes have noticed me is like wait
what you know you should actually
interview so today we're doing Sandman
okay so we're reacting and you obviously
you've seen him before you should we
should set up an interview cuz he's
actually really interesting to talk to
too um so today he's saying imagine a
world without women interesting so we're
about to find out let's see what he says
okay Ellie come here what are you doing
why are my legs so tasty she literally
loves my legs what is you can
like see me in here this video was
brought to you by donation from Gabriel
and here's what he has to say hello Mr
sanman I stumbled across your channel by
pure luck when I was 15 looking at
YouTube commentary videos then came
think before you sleep which Peak my
interest for a year or two until a sand
man advertisement for brave browser
caught my eye curiosity got the best to
me leading to the search for your
channel initially I thought what the
hell is he talking about it all seems so
strange but then I heard the term mtow
at that time I just entered a
relationship with a girl that I found
really cute every time she said I love
you I cringed it puzzled me why is that
Mr Sandman and then one day when idly
browsing YouTube I stumbled upon your
videos again it wasn't about the
information but something you said turn
my world upside down women don't love
men that along with your insights on
female nature and the red pill rage made
me question everything I began to look
at my girlfriend with new found
skepticism okay so I have I have a
slight disagreement with red pill in
well in a way so I don't think women
love men in the way that men love women
yeah cuz men love more unconditionally
but I think most women will not marry
the men that they loved the most so
therefore most men do not experience
genuine love from because in 2023 most
women get married at 31 usually the best
guy they could get was in their 20s
somewhere so you think that women settle
for say the nice guy rather than the guy
that who they actually love so for
example the Titanic why was that so big
see this is an old lady who had kids
with another guy talking about her High
School thing oh wow no think think about
it but I think there's a reason that
resignates with women yeah and I I think
most men are not Jack like most men are
not going to be and what do you think it
is do you think that the women just fail
to lock down the guy who they like when
they like them yeah well I think most
women can't lock down the top most women
go after top 20% of men I I mean most
people aren't going to be top 20% in an
industry why would we expect that
they're going to be in the top 20% of
partner or like girlfriends or wives to
pick from yeah so Mo like it's kind of
like we get access to men that
historically we never would have gotten
access to and there's a reason the dads
used to say no stay away from that boy
because they know he's trouble they know
he's no good or maybe he just has a
plethora of women some women do win they
do get that ring from him but now
especially now more and more it's almost
like those guys nobody wins because
they're kind of in the streets forever
yeah and they kind of yeah they don't
really need to settle for anyone else
yeah like even um now Rihanna was with
Drake and Chris Brown now she's with
ASAP Rocky I would guess Rihanna
probably loved Chris Brown the most yeah
but Chris Brown settled with nobody he's
by himself yeah yeah and I think that's
going to be a more like more men are
going to pick that than did in the past
no I agree without a doubt especially
because like you say the plethora of
women that are available to them now you
know with things like Instagram it just
makes so many more women accessible and
it means that those women also then have
access to someone like Chris Brown
obviously they make they make the
mistake of thinking because Chris Brown
will sleep with me it means that he'll
marry me but you know that's their own
issue yeah there's been a girl on the
show that's actually like gotten
messaged by Chris Brown she like showed
me the DMS wow that doesn't that doesn't
really surprise me no but that's the I
guess that's the the issue so I think a
lot of times like men most men will not
experience genuine like desire from a
woman I think most men will never
experience it no no it's kind of like
they just get the uh you're convenient
for me so I'll find a way of tolerating
you rather than I actually really want
to be in your presence and be around you
even I even remember thinking this in
college like cuz there was a I was on a
team with like I don't know 15 chicks
and I remember thinking like there's
always like this one guy that the girl's
obsessed with and even if she gets a new
boyfriend she's still not as obsessed
with the new guy as the old guy yeah and
I I think you know it's less and less
likely it'll be you the more Partners a
woman has yeah of course of course you
know out of like I don't know 30 men are
are you the best I doubt it you know
probably not her relationship suffered
as a result I even started questioning
her attraction to me despite not being
very tall but I saw real attraction in
her not the typical be a provider in all
settle down scenario then I encountered
hammerhand the mtown monk who taught me
not to waste hate on women my world
hasn't been the same since I discovered
mtow at a young age but I'm not jumping
into it at 18 instead I'm developing my
own philosophy sex should only be used
for procreation and I've embraced your
advice to Define who I want to be rather
than becoming a utility for a woman my
lifelong interest in evolution in space
led me to extensive research on human
mating behavior as well as female nature
here's what I've learned we cater to
women because they're the ones that
produce both men and women the world
isn't as pure as it seems power and
reproduction Drive much of what we do
there's a clear double standard here
women often take credit or resources for
men in need women despite any claims of
male privilege possess intrinsic value
human I's Hedonism may lead to
civilization collapse unless we control
or separate men and women wait so he
said do you think about that if we don't
control or separate men and women I
think there's Nuance to it because it's
like okay there needs to be a clear
definition between the binaries the
binary of gender like gender is a binary
thing right it's it's two things it's
man and woman I'm not going into the
conversation of genders of spectrum
because it bollocks in itself and I'm
not going to go down that road but the
point is is that okay yeah you do need a
clear decisive what it means to be
masculine what it means to be feminine
and people need to understand those
roles clearly however where I would say
Nuance comes into it is you don't want
to divide men and women to the point
where you're turning them against each
other and I and I think unfortunately
that's where we've got to with things
like men going their own way it's
because things have become such a mess
on say the part of the women that men
are no longer happy with the the
scenario that's put in front of them so
he's saying control the women so I
almost I he's like unless we control men
and women I think he's almost saying
control women cuz it just seems like
we're just kind of out of control we're
just going crazy I agree something needs
to be that the reain sort of need to be
pulled in W with women like I do think
that women are the half of the scale
that has just gone way too overboard and
I do think that we need to do something
to bring it back to balance um some
might make the argument that maybe
that's then you know letting men get
just as out of control
um so that we comes back to some kind of
balance but you know I I mean I don't
know the answer if I did yeah I think
men I think mtow when you think about it
mgtow has always existed because most
men haven't reproduced yeah so it's
interesting how it's women didn't care
about mgtow when it wasn't the men they
wanted yeah but now that the men they
want are like you know maybe I'll just
have side chicks for a lifetime it like
enrages them they're like well you you
you can't like men shouldn't sleep
around either and I'm like well we do it
first
most most guys I know that are like very
successful sleep round there was a woman
they wanted to marry young yeah and they
totally wanted to do that and then chick
went to college and broke up with them
and they're like you know and it's
almost like they become mtow because of
the actions of women oh 100% 100%
because you know what what what can they
do when they're being put in a certain
position you know men are problem
solvers so so they look at the
circumstances in front of them and they
say okay this is the position I'm in I'm
going to do something to ensure I'm not
in that position again whereas you know
if it was the flip side women would just
kind of sit there and complain about the
situation and not do anything to change
it and I think men would sign up again
if the risks weren't so high 100% like
they totally so many men would and want
to do that but it's like the risks are
just they're like this is too much if
you could say guarantee that you could
actually know a woman's body count so
like I've seen on on Twitter a lot
recently a lot of men say this rule of
uh I only recently came across this it's
like when a woman tells you her body
count times it by three it's like
they're obviously doing that as some
kind of measure that they felt like they
need to do because of women they've had
experiences with do you know where you
would go Rich if there was a technology
that could detect a woman's body count
you would make so much money oh my gosh
you would make pillion yeah I I'm not
smart enough to come up with it but
there's your million dollar yeah I'm not
I can't what a woman says but what she
does and the most important Point Go
Your Own Way since then my sympathy for
women is diminished while my empathy for
other men is grown I no longer simper
women thanks to my awakened subconscious
when I see a woman in NE I think to
myself she'll get help or why help her
when she already has everything handed
to her regarding my ex-girlfriend she
used to love watching romance movies and
Asian cartoons with me however I never
liked any of those and now I detest them
even more since this discovering the
truth about life when I watch romance
movies or those Japanese cartoons I
analyze them rationally scientifically
and evolutionarily like you I no longer
see women as unique they're like NPCs
but I also think they want to use men
furthermore I'm imaginative and a busy
writing a novel in the science fiction
world where men separate themselves from
women relying on technology for
reproduction after revolting and
fighting against the gynocentric
government this is a riam Mor episode oh
is it really yeah I I've never it's like
um it's like a instead of like human men
it's like they're on this planet and
there's these aliens called the
gazorpazorp and the gazor aops basically
have sex with these robot women they've
invented um and then the robot women
reproduce for them but it's actually
quite a feminist episode because you
have these Savage gazorpazorp aliens who
live out in the mountains and they're
just Savage and they sleep with these
robots but actually it's the it's the
women who invented the robots for the
men and the women are like Gods on this
planet well obviously not
but but wait wow I actually it kind of
is scary to see how technology is
evolving I don't think they could ever
fully re I would be very surprised if
they figured out a way to actually
reproduce without wom they can clone
they can clone that's actually real yeah
what's the sheep called yeah but they've
never done with a person right of course
they have really they can't say they
have of course they have think about
think about like the experiments that
they would have been running after World
War II you know we don't hear about all
of those but come on okay you you know
more about the conspiracy theor stuff so
okay but I bet they've done a human
clone my my thought is if they had
everybody's got phones everyone talks
wouldn't it have gotten out by now no I
just I don't believe in people's ability
to keep secret I I hear what you're
saying um but I do believe in the
government and corporation's ability to
censor information so I reckon there are
people who know I just think like it's
on Reddit somewhere or something maybe
Reddit maybe like you know dark web yeah
the dark web I mean that's a whole
dangerous route in itself but if
anyone's brave enough to go find it find
me a human clone I bet they
exists where men truly go Midtown people
are divided into classes including a
ruling class that undergos rigorous
training to become the rulers and
workers in this world boys are taught to
avoid women and sexual desires are
occurred by drugs a world where men work
now they're in focus on well isn't that
kind of naturally happening with the
food cuz the food is lowering
testosterone doesn't that lower your sex
drive and I know I don't know if they
have studies on this estrogen in the
water yeah but I was wondering if like
women have a certain level of
testosterone and that's probably
lowering too and I would wonder if it's
giving ultimate like the same kind of
effects I don't know I'm not a science
person but I was thinking like if men
let's say men have 10 units of I don't
know how it works but like to say 10
units in women women need two units of
testosterone right I would imagine like
I know when you play competitive Sports
as a woman you um have higher
testosterone and gym girls have higher
sex drives makes sense yeah yeah I've
heard this is it true I don't know but I
mean it it makes sense so because all of
those activities raise your testosterone
so I'd imagine even women getting lower
testosterone would also lower their sex
drive too I I I think so I think I think
both men and women at at least the
younger Generations have a I I'm pretty
sure there's a recent study on this that
we have lower sex drives than ever
before my my prediction for the under
21s I actually think women are going to
be less promiscuous I think there's
you're still going to see a lot of only
fans workers and that stuff but I do
think you are going to see lower like
number of sexual partners because I just
think it's getting more virtual y yeah
that is just my guess I don't know but I
I think and it's going to get more
antisocial so I think you're still going
to see women seeking attention like
sexual attention online but I think
there's going to be less and person
interactions meaning there's probably
going to be less sex so I think the I
see it going that way 100% yeah cuz it's
like um I I look at the difference in
the Gen like in my generation versus
like my youngest sister and my youngest
sister is um like she there she's so so
much of a gamer like I was thinking
about when I was in high school they um
like if I got caught drinking they'd be
pissed but her if she got caught
drinking they would be like oh thank God
she's doing something you know what I
mean they'd be like please just go to a
party
child and so that's I was thinking about
how I don't think that's just like my
family's experience I think that like
under 20 they're so chronically online
cuz you're kind of in between you're 23
yeah and I I I kind of see the shift
more dramatically a little little bit
younger than you I see it like around
2019 like where I think that's because
of when we got phones and that so like
for example I still remember videos and
cassette tapes I mean that might be
because my parents are a lot older than
than most parents but like I still
remember a time where phones weren't
constantly in our hands now it was quite
young don't get me wrong I think I was
about year six I remember everyone
started getting a black year six is like
11 years old 10 11 years old whereas
yeah people who are 1920 they they would
have been like what five yeah so it's
it's you know saying oh a 19-year-old
23y old doesn't sell that far apart but
when you look at say a 10-year-old
versus a 5-year-old like development
mentally is completely different they
like iPads and stuff in front of them
cuz I remember the shift was in eighth
grade that was okay I remember I'll tell
you they're going to say this is my
trauma but whatever I remember like when
I was in eth grade I was like happy gol
lucky right whatever then um I got
Facebook and I remember I was like was I
not invited to something I didn't even
know they were hanging
out so it was the first time I ever even
like knew that I wasn't invited to
things yeah and it was kind of before
that it was like ignorance is bliss you
didn't care cuz 100% like I mean you
might hear about something but like
you're like eh you couldn't see it but
once you see it there's just more of
like a fomo and it definitely added to
the separation of people it added to
like high school clicks and that I think
more so because then it it gave a
private space that wasn't in the school
it was outside of the school for these
sort of you know groups clicks whatever
you want to call it um to be more
prominent and it's more divisive isn't
it because then it's like you know like
uh things like inside jokes like that
would have been accelerated massively
with the introduction of social media
because you know you before you actually
had to be next to each other to and have
something happen to to create an inside
joke about it but then it's like once
it's all online it's like you guys could
just be sending each other vines in the
group chat and then suddenly you've all
got got this group inside joke yeah well
and even also I was thinking about how
it it furthers the clicks too because if
one girl doesn't like another girl and
they see you two are hanging out then
girl three gets met and it's like you're
more of an where before that time in my
life I remember it being more and it
slowly has gone one way like people from
different groups would like people would
have the clicks but they would all kind
of intertwine like maybe one person
group
with Group D then it became more it's
almost like a thing but it's weird to
say that it's weird to say that cuz
you're so young I know but it's kind of
true it's is 100% true it yeah I mean
when I look back to say my secondary
school experience yeah clicks were
political it was definitely political
who you were associated with and you
know who you sort of surrounded yourself
with and and that was all enhanced by
like you know the kind of content that
you were exposed to yeah and techn ology
a world where they've explored
everything about Earth including what's
under the deep sea and so much more it's
a fascinating concept and I love to hear
your thoughts on whether such a world
could work and how women might react
well Gabriel thanks for the donation as
well as the topic I'll get to it in a
moment but first let me tell everyone
about today's sponsor the mtow book
collection part two whether you're
getting camel toone Cambodia don't
includes his classic book now available
in s sorry SP link is down below will
eventually be replaced
by now back to men creating a future
world where cooch will eventually be
replaced by computer code and robots
clown R show there's a scene from the
first season of Westworld in episode 8
which in my opinion is where the show
peaked out where Ford played by Anthony
Hopkins mentions that Mozart
Michelangelo and Shakespeare's
accomplishments happen because human
intellect is nothing more than an
elaborate mating ritual the desire to
impress women and attract a mate and we
do that subconsciously eliminating the
male sex drive with medication the way
you say in your science fiction story
Gabriel might eliminate human drive and
creativity in men that's from Hopkins
that's really interesting that's such an
interesting point do we like experiment
and go after our intellect because it's
a mating mating strategy and like
specifically so he said like the work of
bethoven and Shakespeare Mo whoever he
said like would they have done that if
it wasn't a mating strategy like are
they exercising intellect because
they're doing it to find a mate and if
we then get rid of the need to mate do
we then risk losing human Innovation and
intellect actually I don't think it is
well I don't want to think it is
but okay so this is my my thought
process I think that there are things
that women like men would not invent and
make if it weren't for women so for
example a Roomba the the vacuum cleaner
that does itself okay I I think a guy is
just kind of like well it's just more
simple why am I going to invent this
whole machine but they do stuff like
that because of women but what I think
of without women it would be very much
like
exploration I think music would still
exist I just think it would be more like
um but you can still run the argument of
are they doing that to be the Explorer
that say went to Mars be the Explorer
that colonized the Galaxy I think men
just do that I think that's like
something about being a guy like but
then why is it there which what do you
mean so like I I agree with you I think
men just do that and I think initially
men men will continue to do that you're
saying why is it because I'm saying oh
is evolution Evolution like you know I I
don't know cuz I feel like when guys are
young they still have that in them and
they think girls are gross like yeah but
then it would still it would still be
their present for later in life wouldn't
it oh that's what I'm saying that's why
I say it's really interesting what he
says because I don't I don't have an
answer we can't know yeah is not so
mystery link I've shared it before it's
only one or two minutes long my point is
that the majority of men climb the
tallest mountain and go into the mines
to pull out gold and get rich so they
can go back and get their hands on women
there's a small group of men out there
that are self-motivated enough after
they learn the truth about female nature
to keep going most though however give
up on achieving that would make S okay
anything in life at that point entirely
I was the opposite once I was free of
them I pushed myself to accomplish more
than ever while knowing full well I was
but men always say that they had they
accomplished the most when they got rid
of of women so like they'll say like I
did the most and I worked on myself when
I stopped worrying about women oh I have
I have no doubt that women pose
obstacles to to to to to men I have no
doubt about that however I I do still
think that the initial drive to succeed
conquer explore whatever you want to
call it is there because of mating
strategy and I think perhaps like how
this guy is talking maybe in the Modern
Age you know we have this ability to
sort of rise above above it and uh you
know raise your Consciousness or
whatever above it but I think it has to
be a conscious effort because I do think
that there is some kind of biological
drive there I think the reason that men
are like that is because women are
attracted to it but no doubt women get
in the
way but okay hear me out hear me out
Adam and Eve right Adam was chilling in
the garden he was doing his thing then
Eve came true this [__] caused chaos
yeah women are chaotic no but I'm
thinking like and this is just me
thinking of it from a Biblical point of
view I think Adam I'm guessing he was
still like doing [__] in the guard I
don't know I'm just I'm spitballing here
but I'm like I'm thinking like he was
fine on his own in the garden and then
they brought Eve to help him King wants
to talk of course he was doing stuff in
the garden he literally named all the
animals before Eve came yeah so that I
was
like did you I thought he was going to
keep going so did I
you know so I'm thinking like that's why
I think it's actually something about
being a guy I don't think it's Evolution
this is my thought process if I had to
guess I I don't think it's there because
of women I think men just I don't think
it's there I don't think it's there
because of women I think it's there to
attract a mate so that we can continue
to reproduce let's let's keep watching
act a mate like dangling a carrot in
front of my subconscious are you sure
all you want to do in your life is write
one book or do you actually want to
pursue many other things as well the
main issue I have with your book is that
most men need something to drive them
forward when it comes to motivation if
you publish it most women won't really
care because it's just a book and most
men don't read books anymore they might
write an article about it claiming some
sort of misogyny where men run away from
women and explore the universe only if
it becomes the bestseller though and I
don't see how that's going to happen
considering the most fiction books these
days are written for women if you don't
believe me on that not just find one of
the few remaining bookstores out there
and see what they're selling books for
[__] candles and
pillows I do love
cleine section but I rarely see men inet
another issue with getting men to go out
there into the universe is that that
might actually work if there's small
teams of men with a bunch of different
ships that would be the ideal situation
since getting most men to cooperate is
like hurting cats men only work together
when there's a war or when they have to
make money to pay for and support their
families work for most men is done
begrudgingly yes there'll still be small
groups of men willing to explore the
universe but most will fall prey to
Hedonism and that means that they will
reproduce so one generation to the next
will end up being smaller that means Po
and then you lose you lose It ultimately
in the end this is what I'm saying like
it's so interesting do we then if we
completely separate the Sexes and and
Men completely go their own way and say
no to women do we then we we just lose
everything surely because there's
there's no need to do anything anymore I
like cliche as it sounds I'm a woman
forgive me but like you can't we can't
give up on love like some people want to
and that's no that's no problem but like
we could we risk losing so much I I
agree but my thing is I I I just don't
see men signing up until we know the oh
completely there needs to be reform
things need to be fixed but we cannot
completely give up guys you need
something to drive you the next thing is
going to be po
yeah that's going to be next I mean
we're already in soft polygamy anyway
because I mean women are side it's
talking stages is essentially I'm a side
chick 100% yeah and so it's like we're
kind of in that but I bet you it's going
to become more public yeah I I could see
that crash Hedonism will lead to
Humanity's collapse unless we figure out
a way to get the fertility rate up or
stabilized in a post scarcity civil you
know that's why in Israel um they
introduced um inv vitro and that's how
they got it up and I'm a Catholic we
don't really believe in that but but it
did that is too they did they do they do
have like one of the highest birth rates
which is like 3 point something kids and
I'd imagine I'd imagine like the war and
that sort of thing because um the other
Theory as to why that is is because like
you know the conflict there and so it's
like they they need to have more kids to
like protect the Next Generation and all
that right so I I think that's partially
why too while we aren't technically post
scarcity world today compared to people
a few hundred years ago we definitely
are at the very least give men sex
robots in artificial WBS and only give
them access to them once they perform
specific tasks unless of course those
men can that would solve you know that
would solve the issue so like not just
anyone can that that solves the issue of
motivation and drive because if it's
like you can only the only genes that
will be like carried on by the men who
have to sort of prove something to
qualify for that then then that solves
the motivation issue but it doesn't
solve the whole idea of like do we lose
moart and bethoven do we lose creativity
because then it's like who decides what
qualifies if you get an artificial womb
or not I actually I actually think we're
already losing creativity because of AI
and like I don't really think our
generation has had a Mozart no even like
and it's because of all the information
that we we've got access to as well it's
like are our ideas really our own or are
they something that's gone into our
subconscious memory that we've just seen
somewhere and then we go we create
something we go I've come up with this
originally and it's like well is it
original or do you where did you get it
from even like Taylor Swift is our
Mozart yeah and you know what I actually
I go back and forth on her but I
actually think she's a great songwriter
like I do think her lyrics are very good
they're kind of like whiny I'm the
victim but but we are never ever ever
come on that's a Bop I don't even care
what anyone says getting back together
it's a great song great song No and that
it's catchy it's catchy you know her and
John Mayer didn't work out and we all
profited and anyway so so um but for her
um she I don't know like it's not Mozart
you know what I mean it's more of like
whiny you know while while her lyrics
are clever they are clever come on we
can give her clever lyrics you don't
think they're clever I can't say I've
read enough of her lyrics and enough
detail to know but what I do know is
that to me all pop music is just the
same four chords put in a different
order over and over and over again so
you're probably just speaking to the
wrong person about pop music that's true
and you know what's interesting too if
you look at music from like 50 years ago
it was so much more creative are you
guys have got listened to all the stuff
from the' 70s 8s 60s that is the way to
go I literally but it but my my point is
we're actually already losing creativity
even I was thinking about in sports too
I was thinking when I would watch like
clips and I'm not I'm not even a big b
basketball Watcher so maybe they'll
they're going to roast me in the
comments but when I see clips from the
'90s of like the basketball back then
like it was just they were just doing
these like stunts and stuff like Larry
Bird I think his name is like the moves
they were doing were just very creative
that's true cuz I think about football
and like my dad me and my dad go to
football stadium here together we've
been going since I was about nine and he
will tell me stories of matches he went
to for example he said that he took his
best friend to a match in the 60s they
were like 8 years old and we won like 8
n and like you you in the whole history
of US following our team we've never won
8 nil again and you don't even hear that
in like the Premier League you don't see
teams anymore someone beat someone 8 nil
yeah like 100% yeah everything is just
kind of gone nothing's amazing anymore
you know what I wonder I was thinking
I'm like is that because they used
steroids back then cuz I think it's more
regulated now yeah I mean I don't know
cuz the argument could be made they've
just gotten better at hiding it but I
think they've just been paid more money
now that they've become somewhat lazy
yeah I think that theyve just now I
think everything it's like with
creativity sport whatever you want to
call it like with music as well it's
like okay but now we have uh what's it
called autotune so I just think
everything has just become too
convenient and too easy that people
don't feel the need to perform as high I
even I know someone that like makes
music for movies and he's like I don't
even know how to play because I I'm just
so used to producing yeah he just yeah
he doesn't even have to know he said he
he said he used to know but he hasn't
done it in years cuz he doesn't need it
because he doesn't have to yeah and so
obviously you're not going to get as
beautiful of like like Mozart because
you're not going that deep into the you
know knowledge of it Gabriel I'm also
glad that you got the experience of
being with a woman that was actually
attracted to you looks wise anyway you
don't generally have to question If a
woman is attracted to you when she's
under the age of 25 and in her prime
rooster roller coaster years I bet later
on guys are going to call you an Insel
without realizing that if a woman wanted
you in your Prime then you're no Insel
at all also with regards to women having
intrinsic value I made a video recently
and it should be coming out and it's
called do women have value I've always
pointed out women's intrinsic value that
can be replaced by technology just like
it can replace steak with fish you also
say to believe what women do instead of
what they say I don't believe either
women virtue singal all the time by
helping people with their actions
meanwhile all they're doing is investing
their effort in exchange for Social
Capital that they can call in a favor
for later or use it over the years to
guil trip you that way imagine
understanding that the good things women
do are I always say the biggest I've
said I said this I don't know if this
video or the last one but I always say I
think the biggest red flag in a chick is
spite more more so than even a high body
count more even though this usually
comes with it more so than a sleeve full
of tattoos more I know men like you know
I've heard stories of guys that married
like a homeschool this guy messages me
is life story marri's a homeschooled
chick ends up divorcing him and he's
like look at I remarried this other
chick she's I mean it might end badly
for him but but the second girl is way
more promiscuous but she's not spiteful
not spiteful yeah and spite is horrific
because it's it's way more dangerous in
the future yeah yeah and and he's right
a lot of women like do are always
keeping score 100% And when you're
keeping score you just never win because
like what are we counting for right you
know it's really horrible that like it's
just horrible because I hate it when
women say like I've done this for you
I've done this for you I've done this
for you it's like you you sound stupid
even saying that because by saying I've
done this for you the fact that you
remember what you did and you're
obviously Point scoring how can it be
for him that you're doing it for like
you're doing it for you so you can say
I've done this for you it's not for you
at all that's like some gu some guys
like just don't they'll just say I don't
want anything because they don't want to
be it to be held over their head no I
get that 100% cuz a favor is not genuine
if you're constantly like holding it
over someone's head he's not right about
the fish though you you can't replace
steak with fish is that that what you're
were going to say I am really triggered
by that you can't replace steak I like
salmon I could do I steak or salmon you
could say goodbye to steak for something
no I do like who could say goodbye to
State good that really hurt me when I
finally figured it out that even if they
perform good actions that doesn't mean
they have good intentions also when
you're subconscious stop I think that's
in the Bible somewhere I can't remember
the verse but like it was I think it was
Solomon or something there's some ah
gosh I hate it when these stories I
can't remember but I just know it was
like a king or a general and I think it
might have been Solomon he slept with
his um army officers like General and
that or his wife his General is like
wife and then he sent the wife or the
general out to war so he would die and
then he he ends up marrying the wife
you're such a bad Christian that's David
is it David I get the names I get the
names
confused but and and God was talking
about how it like only he could see his
heart and he like forgave David do you
want to remind me king I have the story
right right feel free to step in at any
point k
David slept with uah's wife and then he
sent him to the warfront see I had the
story it was just the you know yeah but
God still punished David for it though
yeah no but he talked about how it was
um like only he could see his heart it
was something like that and it was like
the point of the story was that even
though he did that bad action like he
felt guilty for it and only he could see
his heart it was something I'm I'm
butchering it but am I am I wrong you
could tell me if I'm wrong no yeah so
like David was repentant
he still got punished for it yeah that's
that's what I meant with the video was
like basically I mean you never know why
someone's doing something no and and how
they react after they've got done that
good deed will ultimately tell you but
the problem is the issue of time because
they could do a whole bunch of good
deeds for for 5 years and then you know
that would might kind of die out for
like 40 years and then in 45 years time
you might start getting the I did this
for you I did this for you that's what's
so dangerous about it is that you don't
know when they're going to throw it back
in your face face but also you don't
in your faceing about them and at that
very young age you're usually in the red
pill rage 2.0 also it's counterintuitive
but we need to collapse the fertility
rate as quickly as possible well under
one we can speculate as to whether or
not the elites want the fertility rates
to decline I say crash them so fast that
it takes out their wealth at the same
time if that's the game they're willing
to play maybe that's why they
demonetized mtown channels and ban them
in the first place in places like Latin
America because we were accelerating to
decline faster than they wanted it they
want a gentle crash and not a
catastrophic one thinking they can
control human nature also as you
mentioned women for the most part are
NPCs and can't explore innovate there
are a few out there that I've run into
that aren't NPCs but they're usually too
busy going on their own Adventures to be
interested in a relationship with a man
usually they're in the few highest
percentage points of introverts they
don't really need men but generally only
so long as the guy offers his services
to them first without them asking that's
for what I've observed and it seems to
be the ethical way to use men such women
only use men if they volunteer for abuse
Gabriel you also mentioned space
exploration but we are in space what
what do you think of what he said about
the elites like wanting the fertility to
crash but not too fast so he's he's
right right they're not thinking about H
they're not taking into account human
nature and if if men do go completely
their own way you know it's not going to
be they do want a gentle decline because
that way you know things like the
economy they can keep that somewhat
under control and then they they don't
essentially lose their wealth whereas
you know if kind of human nature kicks
in and and Men completely say like we're
we're completely checking out here and
then the fertility crashes like you are
[__] over the elites essentially
because then the the elites then don't
have their wealth and it their whole
grand plan falls apart so like yeah
what's their grand plan well they just
they want all the money in the world
don't they they they want all the money
all the control like it it's very easy
to to have this huge divide between like
the elites and then like everyone else
so they don't want it to be they don't
want classes essentially they don't want
poor working class middle class upper
middle class Rich than the elites they
want it completely you are under our
control you produce the things that make
us money and we are up here and and
we're so far apart that there's no way
you can get don't they Wonder cuz I
think about this they they've made such
a crazy culture wouldn't you say that
they um like what I was thinking if they
have daughters won't their daughters
have the same problems because their
daughters are still in the media like
they still hear the Mark Zuckerberg
doesn't let his kids on Facebook the
people who who invent all that
medication we had to take really you
know the the medication they don't let
their kids have it but but everybody the
kids knows is probably going to be on it
because their kids aren around other
normal kids their kids are around other
Elite kids I don't know I just I think
that eventually
somehow the elites will get infiltrated
by the culture because of women somehow
and I think that's kind of what he's
saying I think he's saying like
ultimately human nature is like with men
going their own way they're kind of
figuring out how to play the Elites at
their own game and I agree with that
like it is right and and in theory it
works but I just don't like it because
then you're you know it's it's basically
like well you want to take us out we're
going to take us out first it's B
basically it's suicide isn't it it's
like you know well I wonder if then it
would force I just wonder if men
revolted or like did this then they
would be forced to kind of give them
what they want like at least change some
of the laws or like I don't no no
because they're no because their their
intentions are completely impure so
their their whole like mindset is like
we hate ourselves as Humanity so much
that we we want to dominate it and if
people don't comply to this we'll take
all of us out like I don't think it
would ever get to a point that the would
would negotiate I don't think it would
get to a point where they go okay well
you know this way we're all going to die
so we're going to have to come to some
negotiation where we don't all die no no
no they will just go oh you want to play
us at our own game boom nukes we're all
done I just I just wonder what is the
Sol is there even a solution make Trump
King Trump is king that's my
solution I don't know I was like CU I
was like imagine if Trump was King like
they just took out democracy and just
made Trump a king I had this this
conversation with blessing actually when
we when we all went to that state place
we we were talking for like the best
part of an hour like what's better the
idea of democracy where actually
corruption is just completely like we
act like it doesn't happen but we all
know it does or is it better to have a
monarchy in place where corruption just
isn't even hidden like everyone's honest
about the fact that the world's corrupt
you know what I was thinking sometimes I
question if there are elit that have
this grand plan or if it's really just
the love of money I don't think it's a
grand plan I think it's more than love
of money because when you think about it
I was thinking of the trans movement
money's at the end um and it's basically
they just take these autistic kids yeah
and give them this like marketing cycle
whatever this is the answer to all of
the problems that come I think money is
the grand plan I think it's just you
know money is the goal any way to have
more money if we can Implement control
that way we get more money like I think
that is a grand plan I don't think
there's this written out big agenda
Illuminati type thing that there's
actually any kind of outcome other than
money I think I think money is just the
driving force for evil and they've
become obsessed with money oh and that's
that's why you know it's interesting
when I found out that actually the US
has led in divorce ever since the like
ever ever since the the colonies and
like the the English couldn't believe
the divorces they allowed in the US and
actually this idea that the US was like
a Christian Nation is actually wrong
because it was like these Quakers it was
like these very liberal Christians that
came over and they weren't like
respected by the English and it was kind
of like and that yeah and it was kind of
like when you think about it it messes
up the natural order of the world
because you got in government it used to
go God government men women children
like that was the order and democracy
like they interpreted one part of the
Constitution which I think is argued but
they said there's a separation of church
State yeah yeah yeah yeah and when you
think about it then that puts money at
the top which kind of leads to all of
this stuff because you divide the family
because when you think about it it
doesn't have to be like a plan to divide
the family unit but they think well if
the politicians and the businessmen are
talking they say hey we can sell more
[__] if we sell [__] to your women and
they're like oh you know if we separate
the vote we can control everything
better agreed I don't think I don't
think the goal is we want to destroy the
family unit I don't think that's the
goal I think that is an instrument they
are using to be able to sell more [__]
because if you can divide up the family
then you know you don't have women
asking their husbands anymore can we get
this it's just the women go out and get
it themselves also you you give women
the vote you could have a family where
the wife and husband's values don't
align so you you make the the unit
unstable by them having diff different
values and different political
ideologies um and then that way
you know you you you take away men being
the king of their own home and
essentially I think the whole point of
it is if the men can't be men then there
there's no soldiers to rise up and fight
against the politicians and business
owners and everything you know so I
don't think it's like oh we want to
destroy the family and there's this evil
agenda behind it I just more think it
makes sense for them to divide up the
family because they can make more money
and have more control by doing that well
and even own nothing and be happy in the
last reaction I did they were saying
that when you think about it people
don't even own a house today because
they're just paying the mortgage on the
rest of their life so they don't even
really own it and I was thinking about
it it's really I used to think all of
those harpies that were saying
capitalism is so evil and all that stuff
I I used to just I used to be a
Libertarian okay and so I was like you
know um these are just whiners and
complainers and you can do anything and
I still am a little delusional like I do
think I can do anything a lot of the
time but I actually have gotten to the
point where I actually see all in a way
the left's point where the Love of Money
can lead to a lot of Destruction I agree
I guess the the problem I'm having with
that statement is do do do the lefts do
the oh when I was in college they did I
don't know if that's the same thing now
they've kind of gone more off the rail
but they used to always say that
capitalism was evil that that was that
was such a common talking point like 5
years ago and I just thought they were
lazy
[__] and I still I still do think
that you know I mean I still do think
you can get a job and like do every like
I I do yeah I agree but I'm like you
know what the love of money has led to a
lot of the liberal [__] that's passed
that's that's it yeah that's why I'm
like M cuz it's like and I'm like you
know what I mean I don't think think I
would their conclusion would be the love
of money has led to evil corporations
but back then anyways but now we almost
have a similar conclusion cuz that's
what we're talking about with the elit
like their love of money has kind of led
to them having no morals yeah 100% And
like abortion is a huge business yeah
it's all business all of it I'm like wow
gender affirming care gosh have you ever
seen the pictures of like what the trans
Parts look like when they're switched
look at up on Twitter it's really gross
it's like like a fake whatever it's so I
I was I was bombarded with it I was
bombarded I was on Twitter it was just
like on there I'm like oh my God but but
I saw and you're like let me just share
that nightmare f with you no you should
I feel like every person should watch it
and I'll tell you why because they hide
it they hide what it looks like when
they do the gender affirming surgery and
I think it like contributes like with
the whole abortion thing isn't it
everyone's okay with abortion until
they've seen an abortion they've seen it
and I'm like if they actually saw what
they were doing really to these autistic
people yeah they're just like I I spoke
to um a couple people about their like
like that transition and that's what
they tell me that they're literally just
like most of them were autistic yeah
yeah you want to explore in the universe
is already here all the different
geographies on the earth can probably be
found on other planets as well in your
book you mentioned that there would be a
ruling class of men the Earth is flat
but men don't generally want to be under
the thumb of a ruling class of males we
want our independence the better
solution for the world is artificial
intelligence that was programmed based
on what men voted on to be the best that
way there would be no corruption so long
as it was open- source code in a
blockchain and the rules didn't change
unless 80 or 90 plus% of men agreed to
change them I'm hoping in a few years I
can do tons of personal exploration and
just to wind this down I'm hoping that
in the next few years I can do a ton of
personal paranormal exploration when I
was in my 20s my life was like a great
big episode of xfiles I can only imagine
how crazy it would get if I could travel
the world looking for the Paranormal you
don't need to go to space the ETS you're
looking for are already here anyways
that's it for today so where would I
find a human clone I want to see one you
said they cloned a
goat yeah um oh King can can you look up
the the CL no not a goat a sheep she's
called like she's got a name she called
like Linda or something Linda the lamb
yeah it was in like the ' 50s or the 60s
wow we learn about it in biology I
didn't even know they did that yeah how
what would they do they just grew it out
of like a petri dish or something I
think so yeah they grew out of a petri
petri dish pet petri dish I've been
around you Americans for too long they
grow it in a Petry dish and then they
put it in a sar sheep and then they B it
yeah well I learned something new today
apparently she thinks the US has clones
I don't think or some Maybe not maybe
not just the US I someone's done it
someone's done it I I think that it
would have gotten out I think they they
haven't successfully figured she's like
no I guess it would have gotten out but
like where are those people well oh wait
so do you think cuz they think there's
like satanic Cults and stuff do you
think that basically it was kind of the
love of money cuz someone realized it
worked maybe the satanic stuff and then
they were like oh do it and then
everyone signed like how do you think
the satanic stuff started what do you
what do you mean what do you mean okay
because aren't there like don't they
think the elites have satanic Cults
isn't that a thing so H how did that
what is that the love of money behind it
because they're basically worshiping
Satan for money interesting um I'd
imagine or fortune or fame yeah I I
think it's like cuz they they have this
whole thing of like they drink blood and
that and it's like well I don't think
they drink blood just to drink blood I
think they and it's not even as simple
as drinking blood it's like you can look
this stuff up like stem cell
adrenochrome treatment like they take
the blood of like where they get it from
you know this video is probably going to
get fact checked like anything but like
there's I read some where something
about adreno CRM stem cell treatment and
the idea of like the blood from like
sacrificed babies or aborted babies or
like the for skin that they use in
cosmetics like they take baby for skins
and like put it in makeup and stuff it's
like they do all of that but it's like
you can look at it and you can go okay
well the makeup thing that's to make
money and then the the drinking blood
thing the stem cell adrenochrome stuff
um is because they want to look younger
but again I would link that to money
because it's like why do they want to
look younger because they're they're
celebrities and if they look younger
they're more appealing and then they can
sell more records they can sell more sex
movies whatever it is right wow I just
think I do think a lot of it is the
money thing and I just think that they
will go to to any means necessary to
have any instrument in their Arsenal to
Aid them in that pursuit of money this
makes a lot more sense to me CU I didn't
know if I bought the grand plan but the
making money that makes sense people
yeah I don't think it's I don't think
there's you know I not actually read the
conspiracies on the lizard people so I'm
like that's too far but the aborted
babies and forkin of well they find
didn't they find that planed parent was
like didn't their video come out of them
selling baby Parts par I wouldn't be
surprised yeah I sore it did a couple of
it was weird it just disappeared but
like I I know just like how Margaret
Sanger disappeared off of their website
suddenly she's no longer affiliated with
clood yeah super crazy this is what I'm
saying though was her grand son worked
there this is the point I'm making you
said things would get out right things
do get out but then they are ricated off
the internet they never go main like how
Iva meon is suddenly a horse
tranquilizer since when things just get
changed so someone needs to go on on the
Deep Web and find us the the the person
who's been cloned I bet it's out there
all right guys let us know in the
comments we to find it thank you so much
for watching get yourself a women should
vote t-shirt today like the video on
your way out subscribe to the channel
and we'll talk to you next time